Denis pas de travail pas d'électricité
pas de nourriture pas de rapport sexuel
en fait Koh-Lanta c'est un mélange de
shabbat et du Ramadan
et maintenant voici Tom villa mon
stagiaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il y a là c'est quoi cette
chanson là je pète les plombs tu en as
marre de m'apporter le café ou quoi
bonsoir ça va petit petit débrief de
l'émission de la semaine dernière la
semaine dernière on a reçu Zineb la
journaliste de Charlie Hebdo voilà et
beaucoup de gens sur Twitter ont réagi
parce que Zineb a plusieurs fatwa je le
rappelle la fatwa c'est quand des gens
qui n'ont pas de couilles en veulent à
ceux qui en ont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Thierry très beau plateau ce soir là on
a la belle formule Ardisson une fille un
mec populaire et un mec intelligent et
le mec intelligent évidemment c'est
Denis Brogniart
oui bien sûr mais non mais c'est vrai
Denis ça fait 15 ans qu'il a la
meilleure émission de télé au monde
Koh-Lanta Koh-Lanta c'est le seul boulot
autant lieu de travail et mieux que ton
lieu de vacances quand même
alors Denis Brogniart bonsoir bonsoir
Denis si vous répondez bien à toutes les
questions de Thierry vous aurez droit à
son bracelet de force qui vous donnera
l'immunité sur le plateau de salut
Denis je vous le dis j'ai toujours rêvé
de faire Koh-Lanta voilà bon le petit
souci c'est que vous avez vu mon
physique j'ai pas un physique pour faire
Koh-Lanta à la limite j'ai le physique
d'un mec qui revient de Koh-Lanta
sauf le bronzage oui ça c'est sûr 20
candidats au départ un seul à l'arrivée
des coups bas des alliances des ennemis
prêts à tout même de la perte de poids
bah finalement le Koh-Lanta c'est un peu
ce qui a vécu François Hollande avant
d'être président de la République
alors Denis Briand vous dites cette
émission permet aux anonymes de vivre
des choses incroyables alors attention
Denis ce que c'est exactement dans le
domaine discours que daesh faut faire
attention
Luke ferry bonsoir Luc c'est le 12e
passage de Luc Ferry alors vous savez
quoi Luc je vous ai fait une petite
carte de fidélité voilà
un petit coup de tampon
[Applaudissements]
il est mignon en plus
ça me fait plaisir et vous savez quoi la
13e est offerte avec un kir royal c'est
quand même pas de la merde
rassurez nous lui vous êtes pas ici pour
nous faire une dictée non ça va vous
avez peur évidemment en plus on était
contre la faire aujourd'hui parce que la
semaine prochaine on reçoit Nabilla
ça aurait pu être beaucoup plus drôle
Luc Ferry vous êtes un intellectuel
alors je rappelle quand même ce que
c'est qu'un intellectuel c'est une
personne dont l'activité repose sur
l'exercice de l'esprit qui s'engage dans
la sphère publique pour faire part de
ses analyses de ces points de vue sur
les sujets les plus variés voilà dans
les médias on appelle ça un intellectuel
dans un bar on appelle ça un poivron
bravo
Audrey Lamy bonsoir bonsoir je voudrais
vraiment je l'adore alors pour ceux qui
voilà qui se posent la question non vous
n'avez aucun lien de parenté ni avec
André Lamy ni avec l'ami Ricoré non mais
c'est vrai et puis bon en tout cas très
bonne nouvelle voilà Thierry on a parlé
vous attendez un heureux événement bon
on rassure les téléspectateurs ce n'est
pas Cédric de scènes de ménage le papa
non sauf si jamais à la naissance le
gamin est métisse
en tout cas vous savez que si vous
accouchez sur le plateau c'est un peu
comme dans un avion vous et votre enfant
vous serez VIP dans Salut les terriens
et vous aurez un kiroyal offert
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
[Musique]
Luc Ferry
si aujourd'hui François Hollande devait
être un sujet de philo ça serait lequel
peut-on avoir raison contre les faits ou
faut-il oublier les conneries du passé
pour se donner vers l'avenir
évidemment le deuxième sujet mais
clair Audrey en 2015 vous avez été à
l'affiche de quatre films et à la télé
tous les jours dans scène de ménage ça
fait quoi d'être la Kad Merad au féminin
elle est dégueulasse cette question
Denis brouillard
Denis pas de travail pas d'électricité
pas de nourriture pas de rapport sexuel
en fait Koh-Lanta c'est un mélange de
Chabbat et du Ramadan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et mettez un pouce bleu